when you say standard
what does it mean when you say silver
stand a gold standard again with the
basic question
the term really i think was based out of
gold
the first time this came out was the
gold standard because um so i i said
gold was money at the end of the 19th
century but it wasn't just that
everybody was using gold coins and
trading with gold coins because that's
got a problem of um divisibility so
um a lot of things are worth less than
one gold coin so how do you buy that
thing and the answer was that you
created the monetary instruments that
were backed by gold
and so currencies national currencies
under the gold standard
where specific units of gold and that's
how a gold standard functioned money was
gold but you had pieces of paper
that were redeemable in gold so you
could go to the central bank you'd give
them the
piece of paper the 100 bill or the 10
bill and they'll give you gold in
exchange and they give you a specific
quantity of gold in exchange effectively
the paper was just the receipt for gold
so the paper exactly represented the
amount of gold exactly that was the plan
that was that was what it's supposed to
do but
uh arguably we never had a pure uh gold
standard because
the nature of gold means that the people
who are in charge of the gold
um they have an enormous amount of power
because the gold is concentrated with
them and as long as not everybody shows
up at the same time asking for their
gold then you can make more receipts
than you have gold sure this is good
there's always shady stuff going on but
at least that's the state of goal is the
receipt should exactly represent the
amount of gold there and also when you
say standard
it means that uh
governments
sort of publicly stated that this is
the approved the main way of making
transactions that are monetary so this
is the money this is this is the
official money that you should be using
if you live in this country yes although
i would say it's more like the other way
around it's not that the government's uh
established gold as money it's more like
the
it's more like gold gave the governments
the credibility for their currencies so
governments were not
the ones that made gold money gold has
been money before states were invented
um states if you have a government and
you'd like to have some legitimacy and
you'd like to be able to deal with other
governments on an equal footing you had
to go by the gold standard you had to
have a currency that was redeemable in
gold so that you could trade with the
rest of the world so that people could
um in your country use that currency um
so it's it's it's not that governments
were choosing gold it's more like they
were
having to adapt their own currencies to
gold in order to give their currencies
credibility so there's a dance there
though because if they had to
then why did they switch away from it
after
so there is a dance where the
government's
you know the people
pressure so first of all the the
the basic characteristics of the hard
money
pressures the governments and the people
in terms of what should be used then the
people based on their community the
network effects the way they
the the narratives they tell each other
all that kind of stuff they pressure the
governments
to uh take on a particular money and
then the governments
um you know they like power they like
control all those kinds of things they
pressure the people until different
kinds of narratives so there's a dance
going on in this evolution of what
technology to use for a monetary system
so it's the reason i
it i don't know if governments had to
because they clearly didn't have to
because they eventually moved away from
it
so it but there was pressure probably
yeah but even after they moved away from
it you know central banks until today
they still hold a lot of gold reserves
in fact if you look at 1914 when they
when the world really went off the gold
standard
the amount of gold reserves held by
central banks was a tiny fraction of
what it was as
time went on central banks accumulated
more and more gold what ended up
happening is they prevented their
citizens from using the gold but they
continued to use it so gold continued to
be money up until 1971
because
um effectively the world was on a dollar
standard then the dollars were backed by
gold but then after 1971 even then you
know central banks continued to
accumulate gold because
why would you as a central central bank
want to accumulate pieces of paper
effectively or credit liabilities of
another central bank that can produce
them infinitely
and it's it's it's a lesson that's
becoming
more and more obvious to governments
today you know as we see u.s sanctions
taking say russian reserves or
afghanistan reserves
and this is why you know we see china
and russia have accumulated a lot of
gold over the last 10 20 years so just
to uh return to the question of
uh definitions so what is hard money
versus soft money yes so hard i mean
it's a relative thing but the hardness
refers to the difficulty of producing
more units of the money supply so an
easy money would be a money that is um
relatively easy to make so you can
increase the supply by 10 20 30 40 50 or
something like that so pretty much all
commodities all market commodities other
than gold and silver
they're easy money and they're not
suitable as a monetary medium
because they're being consumed so if you
look at on in the bitcoin standard i
mentioned this metric called the stock
to flow ratio which is the ratio of the
annual production the flow
to the stockpile the existing stockpiles
if you look at all the other metals
they're easy money because they're being
consumed so think about how much
stockpiles of copper there are in the
world today so copper companies
obviously have some stockpiles of copper
um major copper consumers will have
stockpiles of copper but the vast
majority of copper is essentially on a
on a conveyor belt of production from
the mine
straight to the uh consumer good that
it's being used for
so
the existing stockpiles are roughly in
the range of
one year's production if you take all of
the companies i i don't have exact
statistics
it's very difficult to get these but you
know it's roughly in the same range like
if
if copper production were to stop
completely today
we'll have about a year's production
stored in various places
so that makes copper terrible money
because if you started using copper as
money and this is why you know a lot of
people say well money is a collective
illusion money is a
social construct um if we all agree that
something is money then something is
money i think it's completely clueless
and it's usually marxists who believe
this so obviously no understanding of
economics it's completely clueless
because even if everybody in society
decided we wanted to make copper as
money even if we all decided to
collectively
uh take part in this hallucination or
illusion
it would not make copper money it would
just make everybody who decides to take
part in this hallucination poor that's
it it would make copper miners rich it
would make all of the people who chose
copper as money poor and copper would
not be money it can't work because what
happens is because of the fact that the
stockpiles are so small if you buy you
know even if you get the 1 000 richest
people in the world all the world's
billionaires
they get together and they all
dump all of the money that they have all
the stocks all the bonds all the
gold all of the bitcoin everything that
they own they dump it and they buy
copper with it what's going to happen
price of copper is going to go up a lot
but what's going to stop copper miners
from flooding the market with even more
copper than what the billionaires bought
nothing they're going to dump all of
that
extra copper production if the price of
copper is going to go up so you know
there will be a lot more copper mining
than all the other metals a lot of
you know nickel companies and gold
miners are going to switch to focusing
on copper
and then we're going to dump an enormous
amount of copper on the market the value
of copper is going to crash
and the people who chose copper as money
are just going to end up with large
warehouses of very cheap rusting metal
you